and so there was this work with alcohol
that showed that it didn't affect those
monetary
delay discounting decisions you know
nine dollars now versus ten dollars
later and i'm like
getting people drunk and i thought to
myself are you telling me
that that you know getting someone that
people being drunk
is does not cause people at least
sometimes to make
to choose what's good for them in the
short term
at the expense of what's good for them
to yeah in the long term it's like you
know [ __ ] you know like
we see like but in what context does
that happen so that's what
that's something that inspired me to go
in this direction of like
aha risky sexual decisions is something
they do when they're drunk
they don't necessarily go home and and
even though some people have gambling
problems and alcohol interacts with that
the most typical thing is not for people
to go home
and log on and change their their
allocation in their retirement account
or something like that you know like
but they're more likely risky sexual
decisions they're more likely to not
wait the five minutes for the condom
right instead go no condom no right
that's a big effect and we see that
and interestingly we do not see with
those different drugs we don't see an
effect if we just look at that zero
delay condition in other words the
condoms right there waiting to be used
would you
how likely are to use it you don't see
it i mean people
people are by and large gonna use the
condom yeah so
and that's the way most of this research
outside of behavioral economics that
just looked at condom use decisions
um very little of which has ever
actually administered the drugs which is
another unique aspect
but they usually just look at like
assuming the condom is there
but this is more using behavioral
economics to delve in and model
something that and i've done survey
research on this
modeling what actually happens like you
meet someone at a laundromat
like you weren't planning on like you
know one thing leads to another they
live around the corner yeah
these things you know and like we did
one um
survey with with men who have sex with
men and found that uh
25 of them 24 about a quarter
reported in the last six months that
they had unprotected
anal intercourse which is the most risky
in terms of
uh sexually transmitted infection um uh
in the last six months in a situation
where they would have used a condom but
they simply didn't use one just because
they didn't have one on them
so this to me it's like if unless we
delve into this and understand this
these sub-optimal conditions we're not
going to fully address the problem
there's plenty of people that say yep
condom use is good
i use it a lot of the time you know it's
like
where is that failing and it's under
these sub-optimal conditions which in
frank if you think about it it's like
most of the case
action is unfolding things are getting
hot and heavy someone's like
you got a condom ah no it's like do they
break the action
and take 10 minutes to go to the
convenience store or whatever
maybe everything's closed maybe they got
to wait till tomorrow
and though there's something to be uh
studied there
on the that just seems like an
unfortunate set of circumstances like
what's the solution to that
is uh i mean um
what's the psychology that needs to be
uh
like taken apart there because it just
seems like that's the way of life we
don't expect the things that
right to happen are we supposed to
expect them better to
be like be self-aware enough about our
calculations
or you see the 10-minute detour
to a convenience store as a kind of
thing
that uh we need to understand um
how we humans evaluate the cost of that
i think in terms of like how we use this
to help people
yes it's mostly on the environment side
rather on the on the
individual side yeah although those
those interact so it's like
you know in one sense if you're
especially let's say you're going to be
drinking or using another substance that
that
is associated with you know a stimulant
um alcohol and stimulants go along with
risky sex
you know good to be aware that you might
make decisions just to tell yourself if
you might make a decision that
that is gonna that you wouldn't have
made in your sober state and so
hey throwing a condom in the in the
you know might be you know a good idea i
think at the environmental level just
more condom of it i mean it highlights
what we know about just making condoms
widely
available something that i'd i'd like to
do is like
reinforcing condom use and you know so
um
you know just getting people uh used to
carrying a condom everywhere they go
because it's such once it's in someone's
habit if they are saying like a young
single person and
you know it's you know they occasionally
have unprotected sex like training those
people like what if you got a text
message
you know once every few days saying ah
if if you show me if
send back a photo of a condom within a
minute you get a reward of
five dollars you could shape that up
like that it's a process called
contingency management it's basically
just
straight-up operant reinforcement you
could shape that up with no problem
and and um i mean those procedures of
contingency management giving people
systematic rewards is like
for example the most powerful way to to
to reduce cocaine use in addicted people
and um uh but
but by is saying if you show me a
negative urine for cocaine
i'm gonna give you a monetary reward and
like that has huge effects in terms of
decreasing cocaine use
if that can be that powerful for
something like stopping cocaine use
how powerful for that could that be for
shaping up just carrying a condom
because
the primary unlike cocaine use here
we're not saying you can't have the the
main reward like you could still have
sex
and you can even have sex in the way
that you tell yourself you'd rather do
it
you know if the condom is available you
know so
you know like you're not you know it's
relatively speaking it's way easier than
like not using cocaine if you like using
cocaine
it's just basically getting in the habit
of carrying a condom so that's just one
idea of like
well there could be also the
capitalistic solutions of like there
could be a business opportunity for like
a door dash for condoms
oh yeah like i thought about this
within five minute delivery of a condom
in any location like uber forgot himself
i thought about it not with condoms but
a very similar line of thinking
a line that you're going into in terms
of of uber
and people getting drunk when they
intend they into the bar playing to have
one or two
they end up having five or six and it's
like okay yeah you can take the
the cab the uber home yeah but you've
left your car there it might get towed
you might like there's also the hassle
of just you know you want to wake up
tomorrow with your hangover and forget
about it and move on yeah like
and i think a lot of people in their
situation and they're like screw it
i'm gonna take the risk just get it you
know what if you had an uber service
where two
um you know you have uh uh uh
two so some a car come out with two
drivers
and um one of them two sober drivers
obviously
and they and and the person they the one
driver drops off the other that then
drives you home in their car
in your car yeah so that you can i mean
i think a lot of people would pay 50
bucks
it's going to be more than a regular
uber yeah but it's like it's going to be
done
i got the money i already i already
spent 60 bucks at the bar tonight
like just get the damn thing done
tomorrow i'm done with it my car i wake
up my car's in front of my house
i think that would be i think someone
could i'm not going to open that
business so
like if anyone hears this and wants to
take off with that like i think it could
help a lot of people
yeah definitely an uber itself i would
say helped
a huge amount of people just making it
easy to
make the decision of going home uh not
driving yourself
i read about in austin where they i
don't know where it's at now where they
outlawed uber for a while you know
because of the whole taxi cab union type
thing and
and how just yeah there were like hordes
of drunk people that were
uh used to uber that now didn't have a
cheap alternative
uh so just uh
we didn't exactly mention you've done a
lot of studies in sexual decision making
with different drugs
is there some interesting insights or
findings
on the difference between the different
drugs
so i think you said meth as well
so cocaine is there some interesting
characteristics
about decision making that these drugs
alter versus like alcohol
all those kinds of things i think and
there's much more to study with this but
i think
the biggie there is that the stimulants
they create risky sex by
really increasing the rewarding value of
sex
like if you talk to people that are real
especially that have are hooked on
stimulants one of the biggies is like
sex on coke or meth is like so much
better than sex without and that's
a big part of what why they have trouble
quitting because it's so tied
to their sex life so it's not that your
decision making is
broken it's just that you uh well you
allocate
it's a different aspect of their
decision yeah on the reward side i think
on the alcohol it works
more through disinhibition it's like
alcohol is really good
at reducing the ability of a delayed
punisher to have an effect on current
behavior in other words there's this bad
thing that's going to happen tomorrow or
a week from now
or 20 years from now um
being drunk is a really good way and you
see this in like rats making decisions
you know a high dose of alcohol makes
someone
less sensitive to those consequences so
i think that's the lever that's being
hit with alcohol
and it's the more the just the
increasing the rewarding value of sex
um by the psycho stimulants on that side
we actually found that it
and it was amazing because like hundreds
of millions of dollars have been spent
by nih to study the connection between
cocaine
and hiv like we ran the first study
on my grant that like actually just gave
people cocaine
under double blind conditions and showed
that like yeah when people are on coke
like their ratings of sexual desire even
though they're not in a sexual situation
yeah you show them some pictures but
you're just saying
they're horny like you get subjective
ratings about like how sexual how much
sexual desire are you feeling right now
people get horny when they're on
stimulants and
um do you have a lot of people say duh
if they really know
these drugs but that's a rigorous study
that's in the lab that shows
like there's a plot right the dose
effects of that the time course of that
yeah it's not just please tell me
there's a paper with the plot
that shows dose versus uh uh
evaluation of like horniness yeah we
didn't say horniness we said sexual
arousal
yeah basically yeah there's a plot i'm
gonna find this plot right i'll send it
to you there was
one headline from uh some publicity on
the work that said
horny cocaine users don't use condoms or
something like that
like something like journalists i
wouldn't have put it that way but like
yeah that's right
i guess that's what it finds
you